[Music]
hey what's up guys ANCA Bhd here and my
favorite tech of the year for 2019 was
that the Lao optics
probe lens it's of course an incredibly
fun and unique lens you don't see
anything like it usually but it enabled
many of the shots you just saw in that
little montage and of course has made
fun many shots you've seen during videos
during the course of the year it's made
shooting tech a lot more fun but of
course it's a $1500 super specialty lens
it didn't even come out this year I just
sort of discovered it this year so
instead of that sort of useless bit of
information I figured why not get
together some of my favorite creators
and have us all share our favorite tech
of the Year 2019 whether we discovered
it this year or it came out this year
stuff that made our year better in text
that's exactly what we did so sit back
relax and enjoy some of our favorite
creators talking about their favorite
tech of this year hey I'm Dave and my
favorite piece of tech from 2019 is a
device that was notorious for getting
really hot this is the not a
flamethrower and let me tell you why I
like it I've always loved fire I mean
who doesn't this is the greatest stuff
ever and to package it into this
controllable portable device
greatest piece of tech 2019 you've
probably seen my laser iPhone back glass
repair video lasers are really what's
interesting to me this year yeah all of
the new cell phones are really good and
all the new headphones are really good
but when everything is really good it's
hard to pick a favorite so that's why I
was taking with lasers
I found this pretty interesting little
piece of tech while I was working on my
team trees workbench it can very
accurately using a laser measure
distance up to 65 feet with an eighth of
an inch accuracy there are two little
openings up at the top of the box one is
for emitting the laser and the other is
for reading how long it takes for the
laser to bounce off of whatever it's
shooting at the little sensor can tell
by the reflection how far away an object
is it's pretty instantaneous it does
cost about twice as much as a normal
tape measure but when you're measuring
lots of things it might be worth it
lasers my favourite tech of 2019 would
be the iPhone 11 Pro primarily because
of this wide angle lens I actually use
my iPhone a lot to shoot run-and-gun
simple b-roll shots for my videos just
because it's so convenient so having
access to that new lens for cool slow-mo
shots like this just makes me really
happy my favorite piece of tech for 2019
not an easy question iPod air pod where
they called air pod Pro or up there are
up there also the iPhone 11 is one of my
favorite iPhones ever but my favorite
piece of tech my favorite piece of tech
is definitely the folding phone not
necessarily the Samsung fold and not
necessarily the razor hole which I've
got one of right here but folding phone
technology for me is my favorite most
exciting piece of technology to go into
consumers hands in 2019 it doesn't
matter how much top tech I pack on my
back all of it is worthless if I can't
keep it charged on the road so mister
Mobile's MVP is a battery pack but stay
with me it's a cool one this is the
Sherpa 100 PD by gold 0 the 100 means
it's the biggest battery you can bring
onto an airplane
and the PD is for power delivery at
sixty watts that means it can charge my
laptop on the go and the cheap plate up
top means it can charge a phone at the
same time it's not cheap and it's not
small but it is the best battery pack
I've used it's my top choice for anyone
who needs to stay charged while staying
mobile my favorite piece of tech from
this year has to be the Asus Zenbook pro
duo with an i-9 r-tx 2060 32 gigs of ram
it enables me to travel with a laptop
that is similar to desktop speed because
well we can't all travel with an imac
pro marques but yan the foreign factor 2
displays i mean somebody to displace hey
what's going on marques this is sean
evans host of hot ones and i want to
take a second to shout out my favourite
piece of technology of the year these
right here the bose 700 noise cancelling
headphones
now when you travel as much as we do
popping up our budget set all over the
place you need something that'll help
you black out the noise especially on
airplanes and ever since I got these I
have not heard a baby crying or like the
pilot getting on the horn telling us to
put on our seat belts haven't had an
update in a year and it's all thanks to
these bose noise-canceling 700
headphones emphasis on the noise
cancelling my favorite piece of tech
that i've discovered this year is my
Nintendo switch because it's completely
changed how I feel about traveling now
I'm like hey I have an 11 hour flight
and before it was obviously
our flight hi everyone canoopsy here my
favorite tech of the year is surprising
it's the new 10.2 inch budget iPad it's
a great deal and even more so on sale
has Apple pencil smart keyboard and iPad
OS support now I love the iPad pro and
it's kind of my main computer at this
point and the 10.2 inch iPad is
basically a budget version of that
tablet it really is amazing and let's
even more people try that fantastic new
iPad OS experience I'm gonna go with the
obvious because I'm a photographer
that's pretty much all that I do I take
photos for a living the fact that I can
take photos with the iPhone 11 Pro Max
and post them to my portfolio and people
can't really distinguish if they were
taken with a smartphone or a mirrorless
or DSLR camera that to me is a
significant leap forward in technology
that is awesome so having something in
my pocket that I use every single day
that I travel with that's always right
there that can rival you know most case
photography cameras that that's sick my
favorite tech from this year would have
to be the iPhone because I bought a lot
of them and gave them away also it'd be
really funny if you put what I'm about
to say at the end of the video put this
next part at the end of the video hey
you probably need a little break from
all that Apple stuff right don't worry I
got you my favorite tech in 2019 is this
the samsung q 900 are a KTB and don't
let the AKA height fool you because
there's really not a lot of a.k content
right now so that's not the reason that
I'm hooked on this TV the reason why is
the active aka upscaling
so 1080p upscale looks sharper than most
4k TVs and 4k upscale is just incredible
so every time that I watch movies are
content on any other TV and go back to
this one I notice immediately it's
noticeably sharper and brighter hey
everybody I am dieter from the verge I'm
out near Saint Cloud Minnesota visiting
my family for Thanksgiving it is
freaking cold but I want to tell you my
favorite gadget was and it's a this
thing right here the Apple watch series
5 and it's not that I love the always-on
screen that's that I got the cellular
version because this is the year that I
got locked into iMessage so I could talk
to my family but sometimes I just want
carry one phone I don't wanna have both
of the hundred phone and an iPhone and
this thing lets me do it I can just
carry an Android phone around so there
you go it's cold what's up guys
super safe here my favorite piece of
tech of 2019 it's gonna be the samsung
galaxy fault now I know I know it's not
perfect it's super fragile it's super
expensive and it's got a super small
front display but I've not been this
excited about any smartphone in a very
long time and in my opinion this is the
biggest innovation that we've seen in
the smartphone space in a very long time
as well the fact that I can have a
tablet sized display which I can simply
fold and put in my pocket is amazing and
it gets me super pumped about the future
of foldable devices marques thank you so
much for having me my favorite piece of
tech is probably the the DJI Osmo pocket
really fantastic quality and it's it's
almost stupid proof which makes it
perfect for me
Linus from Linus tech tips here and I
chose AMD's Rison third gen series of
CPUs they're great for gaming which I
love of course but the real reason I
chose them is that they're ideal for
anyone who wants to do more than just
gaming with their PC like creating
YouTube videos with the rise in 3600 we
built a 4k capable video editing
workstation for under a thousand bucks
that just wasn't feasible even a few
short years ago also honorable mention
to LG's OLED TVs with g-sync variable
refresh rate support it has been a great
year for smartphones the iPhones are the
best they've been in years however what
I'm really excited about this year is
the oneplus 70 at this kind of price it
is honestly one of my favorite Android
phones I have ever used full stop and a
big part of that is the screen it is so
smooth so responsive everything is so
all optimized it's a slightly better
camera away from being an absolutely
killer phone as it is it's just really
really good no not you iPhone 11 awkward
not you either air pods Pro don't make
this weird no I'm gonna zag instead of
Apple zig and go with the oculus quest I
know what you're thinking
with all the controversies the only
thing worse than Facebook in your
browser just has got to be facebook on
your well face but if we separate the
technical achievement from the
company for just a moment this is the
first full-on fully independent we are
set up no gaming PC no room sensors just
you a headset a set of controllers in
Star Wars
thanks Marquez what's up guys aaron here
from the mysteries the boss channel and
my pick is the samsung galaxy fold on
one hand and I fully mean this it is a
mind-numbing ly annoying phone to use
the front screen is just too small to do
even a lot of casual tasks and the big
screen is too square most apps they're
designed for normal tall smartphone
displays so with the folds you'll be
constantly finding applications that are
either cut off on the top and the bottom
or ones that only take advantage of 50%
of your screen but I don't think I've
ever been this glad that a tech product
exists it's really promising start to
the flexible future what's going on guys
- travis consumer and my favorite tech
of 2019 has to be the asus zenbook pro
duo asus came out with something
completely different and i'd really like
the step that they took with the
additional screen at the bottom now you
do get that keyboard that's a little bit
lower but it is a nice feeling keyboard
typing on it is a really good experience
you do have that interesting trackpad on
the side which also doubles as a
numbered pad and there are just a lot of
cool things here 4k screen oled a
graphics card so you could do some
gaming asus knock this one out of the
park
and made me look at laptops differently
for this year alright so that is it a
few of your favorite creators and their
favorite pieces of tech for the year big
shout out to everyone who participated
and sent in their clips and I'll have a
link below to everyone who had their
favorite piece of tech and I'll have a
link to every piece of tech we talked
about until the next one catch you guys
later peace
put this at the end of the video ah
that's hot like if you included the part
where I said put this at the end of the
video and all that's hot that'd be funny